une mise en garde maintenant emprunter
pas sérieuse mise en garde maintenant à
tous les éventuels gagnants du loto vous
savez qu'il ya une très très grosse
cagnotte la semaine prochaine 35
millions de francs et grâce à vous jean
teulé et grâce à la cité anglaise est en
tout cas grâce à vous je le répète nous
disons attention danger
ah oui là ya danger parce que jouer au
loto c'est pas grave je pense que le
français moyen doit veiller joué on a
pas mal bossé sur d'avancé mais mais il
faut espérer ne pas gagner avant non
parce que ça c'est pas terrible et des
histoires terrier oui il ya des gens ils
y vivent normalement tout va bien et
tout ils jouent au loto et manque de
chance y gagne ils se prennent une
overdose de bonne heure le train du
bonheur que ça passe dans la tête
caceis afu une vie en lèvres
démonstration avec un reportage tourné
près d'epinal regarder un numéro genre
que jean-louis trop j'envoie khiate
j'envoie saint-jean voix 6 roger girard
qui travaille au rayon poissonnerie de
la coop de golbey près d'epinal a gagné
au loto
232 millions de centimes un numéro en
vaut deux jean louis 3 mais le destin
lui aussi a coché trois cases résultat
trois morts le frère le père et roger
gérard lui même
quant à la mère pioche le désespoir seul
et bien désemparés elle ne veut plus
voir personne et se demande encore ce
qui s'est passé un numéro
genre tu sais vous madame qui avait
validé le bulletin de roger-gérard
c'était un joueur régulier et alors le 5
novembre 77 roger-gérard apprend qu'il a
gagné 2 132 millions et rentre chez sa
mère jean luc son frère chômeurs et
jaloux il trouve aussi que c'est injuste
et se jette sous le train
un numéro aux gérard qui ne buvait que
de l'eau fait entrer à la maison des
plaques offre deux mercedes de champagne
et de whisky comme pour les riches il
fait goûter à son père le père tout ça
bon un an plus tard il meurt d'une
cirrhose du foie de mort en briques
rouges girard qui commencent à trouver
que l'addition est lourde continuent
d'arroser sa chance mais avec de plus en
plus de désenchantement
il écrase aussi contre des arbres cette
mercedes tellement ils ne distinguent
plus bien la route de sa vie la route
qui mène au casino de vittel où il perd
de plus en plus les rares fois où il
gagne au lieu de faire changer l'argent
il fait monter les plaques de 100 sacs
en porte clés et les distribuer à tout
le monde sait qu'un jeune homme et à
roger qui ça peut arriver
ce 3-1 ce coin peel fortune aussi
importants peuvent se laisser griser et
peu mousser se laisser impressionner par
des des propositions qui leurs sont
faites par des gens peu scrupuleux qui
les entoure
des gens peu scrupuleux et des faux amis
quémandeurs roger en rencontres tous les
soirs dans les boîtes de nuit où il va
avec sa mère il perd ici ces dernières
liasses de billets
[Musique]
landre trois 3 morts
roger-gérard seul écoeuré ruine et meurt
dans la misère d'une cirrhose du foie
cinq ans après avoir gagné presque jour
pour jour
24e ont bousculé un peu touché aux
rations 26e au moins 100 millions en
fait la chance à porter 232 millions
mais elle avait aussi trois morts caché
derrière son dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]